Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's again, and we're going to be talking about this presentation of feeding
cancer, a simple understanding, a pathway management. If you
remember your high school biology, much of this will be review,
but I think this could help understand just how we want to stop
some specific habits that could help
propagate cancer. This is just a very simplified picture of how food goes into your body.
Food starts up here at this diagram right here. It breaks down into glucose, so all food that you eat is going to eventually
break down into smaller particles. Carbohydrates are going to break down to glucose,
quickest even proteins and fats will break down to glucose for energy in your body. That's how your body
makes energy and needs glucose. And you've heard it said that cancer feeds on glucose. Cancer does need glucose.
What we want in our body is that we want glucose to go the right pathway so that it's making energy.
So it's making energy for ourselves, and especially in the mitochondria, so it really gives us a good log life.
Glucose goes through glycolysis, which is a step-by-step pathway, which makes two little ATP energies,
molecules, but through glycolysis it ends in peruvate. And at this point, when it ends in peruvate, it has a choice.
Now, normally it's going to want to follow that arrow.
Following that arrow, it's going to bring it down into the crev cycle. As it breaks it down into a
sealed coenzyme A, and then eventually it goes into the crev cycle. And this is where we really get a lot of energy production.
This is what you may remember some of these works from high school biology. But this is what will eventually give us longevity.
We got a lot of energy production. We don't have fatigue. Our bodies are working correctly. Our mitochondries are supplied with energy to do all these different pathways that we need to do in our body.
By the way, this chart is a thank you to Dr. Ben, who's seeking health.org has done this marvelous work, charting out some different metabolic pathways. Shout out to him.
But this is what we want. Food breaks down into glucose. Glucose breaks down into smaller molecules.
Goes into different cycles. This case the crev cycle makes a lot of energy for ourselves. We don't have fatigue.
But there are some limiting factors. If we look right here, this is a limiting factor. This is an enzyme pathway right here that is required for breaking down pyruvate to a sealed coenzyme A in order to go into the crev cycle.
And if you've ever heard me lecture before, I used to speak a lot about this. This is really what I used to call your getting in shape enzyme.
Because your ability to break down this pyruvate into a sealed coenzyme is really what we would term in late terms as beaded shape or not beaded shape.
If I could break down pyruvate to a sealed coenzyme A quicker, I am in better shape. So when I haven't worked out for four years, and I go start walking, and I get really stiffened soar, that stiffened soar, this is because the limitation of this enzyme right here.
It's a time-dependent enzyme. It is the more you use it, the more substrates your body creates, and that are shunted towards this enzyme so it will move this pathway quicker.
But in order to protect you, because you haven't worked out for four years, this pathway is halted, and it goes down that center pathway, and it goes to lactate or lactic acid.
So you produce a lot of lactic acid when you haven't worked out for four years, and your muscles are stiff and sore, and you're achy, and you can hardly get out of bed. All of that is lactic acid.
That's not good. We don't want to be producing lactic acid, but if we're starting to get in shape and we're starting to exercise, you don't have a choice. You have to go through that phase.
So we can support this pathway, and that's what we're going to talk about today.
So this pathway is an enzyme that is dependent on moving the pathway in this direction, it's called pyruvate dehydrogenase.
And any deficiency in this enzyme is going to slow this conversion rate, and the use of this enzyme is going to slow the conversion rate.
This is the importance of regular exercise, and we'll talk about that.
We need to increase the rate of conversion from pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme.
That is your new life goal.
So when someone asks you do you have goals in life, you can say yes, I do.
My first goal in life is to increase the rate of conversion from pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme. What's your goal?
And just look at the person's face. But that is really your goal.
If you have cancer, you want to prevent cancer, or you even want to prevent fatigue.
And all sorts of other disorders in your body, because if you can't make energy especially in the mitochondria of your cells, you are going to have all sorts of hurts in your body.
So if you look at this little chart here, there are some things that could block this.
And we want to deal with some things that could block this. So we already mentioned B. Don't have shape.
It could cause a delt regulation of PDH. But there are some things that could block this.
What is this other compound called hypoxic inducible factor 1?
It's actually hypoxic, inducible factor 1a is the final analog that blocks this.
It's a gene that can be up-regulated in certain conditions. That means there could be more of it in certain conditions.
So we want to do everything to lower the concentration of HIF1 in our body.
We want to do everything to push that conversion factor and increase pH in our body. That is our goal.
HIF1 gene is up-regulated in hypoxic conditions, meaning where there's not a lot of oxygen.
Well, that gets us back to, if I'm not exercising and breathing it, getting a lot of oxygen in my body and increasing the oxygen stores in my body, that's going to be an issue.
If I have anemia, because I have B12 deficiency, because I have iron deficiency, because I'm heavy metal toxicity, because I have carbon monoxide poisoning.
And we're not talking about severe carbon monoxide poisoning that's leading you in the hospital.
We're talking about braided toxins in your workplace, braided toxins in your home, sleeping under your garage.
Or over your garage, if you have a talk under garage, all these kinds of things over a long term can decrease our oxygen carrying capacity.
And when we decrease our oxygen carrying capacity to the cells, then we have a hypoxic, a relative hypoxic condition to what should be normal.
And that up-regulates HIF1.
Another thing that up-regulates HIF1 is an increased nuclear factor capabeda.
NFK capabeda is a compound that's released in a chronic infection state.
So, I've read much about NFK in the past, so look at some of the chronic infection videos on how that could cause cancer and other disorders.
But a chronic Lyme disease, a chronic H. Pylori, a chronic M. Ste. Bar virus.
There's many subclinical chronic diseases that people don't know they have, and are not causing them to be quote-unquote sick.
They don't even know they have H. Pylori.
They've lived a normal life, and then all of a sudden they got cancer.
And it's caused by H. Pylori.
And they had no idea that they were carried around this subacute, subclinical, chronic infection for the last 20 years.
That is so, so common.
It increased all sorts of cytokine production, and NFK capabeda is just one piece of that.
That increases hypoxic inducible factor.
It decreases your ability to move pyruvate to acetylchlorinzyme, and it pushes pyruvate down another pathway.
That's not good.
So these hypoxic conditions, increased chronic infections, and the third one that we found that increases H. I. F. 1 is a decreased colonization of gut bacteria,
because it's been found that certain gut bacteria in a healthy gut bio,
remember there's good bacteria that live in your gut that do all sorts of good things.
One of the good things that it does is it makes chemicals to help you move oxygen.
So with all these things take place, this could be the perfect story to move pyruvate towards lactic acid production.
And we just have this increase in a baseline of lactic acid production in ourselves, and we just don't even know it.
And this is the person like me at different times of my life, where you can't even go out and walk in a block as a workout.
You just it's difficult to do.
You push towards lactic acid production, all sorts of bad things happen.
You end up with metabolic disorders, dashes of fatty liver, we don't call this fatty liver disease,
that has nothing to do with alcohol, cirrhosis, diabetes, hyper cholesterol issues, and cancer.
One of this, this is like the diseases of America right here.
It is estimated that 90% of Americans have fatty liver disease.
Diabetes is rampant, and cancer is one and two Americans are getting cancer.
This pathway is so important, not only prevent for prevention, but if you do have cancer, we do not want to move towards this pathway.
The reason why lactic acid feeds cancer is because then cancer cells can get their glucose solely through glycolysis.
It makes it easier to get their glucose, and of course you've heard that cancer feeds on glucose.
Well, this is how cancer feeds on glucose through glycolysis through lactic acid.
So I said there's three pathways that could be pushed.
So if this pathway is that center pathway is being pushed and ended up in doubt at the bottom, you end up with prediabetic state.
You have fatty liver disease that I'll guarantee you that people don't know that they have fatty liver disease.
Or I should say and or it goes towards this third piece of the triangle here.
In the case of where a person has Candida infections, anaerobic microorganisms, it goes towards this pathway and forms acetyl aldehyde.
Now we see this all the time when we're looking at genetic pathways of our patients, where these genetic pathways,
the methylation pathway and the pathiety pathway are blocked through the because of the presence of an increased concentration of acetyl aldehyde.
Acetyl aldehyde is a byproduct of these anaerobic microorganisms, the most common that you think of with this is Candida.
So a chronic Candida infection increases acetyl aldehyde concentrations and blocks several metabolic pathways, not good.
When we have methylation and methydic pathways blocked, we're not creating SAME, we're not creating methylated tetrahedral folate.
And our energy goes down, our fatigue increases, it just blocks just about every pathway in our body.
That pushes us in itself, pushes us towards lactic acid production, it increases our risk for cancer as well.
So how do we deal with this? So what are we supposed to do with this?
We want to push it towards this left side as we're looking at this diagram here.
How are we going to push it towards this left side? What are we going to do?
So we need to support methylation pathways, that's important.
We need to correct some promoters of these destructive pathways.
We need to check for cofactors, these are positive things that we could do.
So what does it look like in a practical step approach?
So this is why we have now come to checking for SNP defects in all our patients.
Now what's a SNP defect? That's a genetic SNP stands for single nucleotide polymorphism.
That's a genetic, epigenetic defect that could occur because of toxins in our environment,
to the exposures to toxins in our environment that creates a genetic defect in us
that then we could pass down to our children.
So my mother might not have had it, my father might not have had it,
but because of my toxic exposure to lead,
now I have this genetic slipped effect, and now my children have a possibility of having it.
That's what's called an epigenetic defect.
These are becoming rampantly coming in our society,
and it doesn't guarantee that you're going to have problems,
but it increases the risk if you add other factors,
like we're deficient in cofactors, we're living a problematic lifestyle.
We have high stress in our life.
It just adds to the whole piece of the puzzle where we could have serious complications.
Secondly, we want to correct promoters of destructive pathways.
So what is the promoter of the destructive pathway here is really want to decrease HIF production.
So how do we decrease HIF production?
Because that's a blocker of the PDH conversion factor.
We need to increase PDH so we can convert pyruvate to acetylcholids MA.
Remember, you do life goal.
So we can decrease the things that block it.
So the number one thing that blocks that is HIF.
How do we do that?
We increase oxygenation of our tissues, exercise breathing techniques,
and we work out healing the gut.
That's why we do that with every single patient.
You think, well, I don't have colon cancer.
I have brain cancer. What in the world am I working on my gut for?
It's for things like this.
There's other reasons why we need to heal your gut.
But this is a big piece of it.
And then check and support the cofactors.
Cofactors are different nutrients that help drive the pathway.
Or you better said, these are nutrients that are dependent for the pathway to be driven.
So alpha-lapolac acid is a great driver of this pathway.
And B vitamins.
That's why we put everybody in a good B multiple.
So the multiple B vitamin is essential for almost every metabolic pathway and detox pathway.
There is in your body.
And we are so deficient in B vitamins.
This is a huge thing.
So even we can have everything else going right.
But in fact, we can, this is an issue in overexercising too.
Well, this is to be because I run a marathon every week.
Well, you're in a category of overexercising.
You're depleted all your nutrients.
And you're in the same situation.
So it's all about balance.
There's nothing good, nothing bad.
Even this pathway is not good or bad per se.
It's good to create lactic acid because it keeps you from injury yourself.
That's what argument that people have that cancer really isn't a disease.
It's a way for the cell to stay alive in a hypoxic environment.
Well, of course it is.
But we don't want that.
So how do we prevent that?
We decrease the hypoxia.
We decrease the HIF factor.
So we increase oxygen stores.
We exercise.
We heal the gut.
We add cofactors to our diet.
We change our diet and good food.
Push the methylation pathway in the right direction.
And it can really help overcome this.
I hope this helped you understand that.
This will have lots more videos regarding this and other issues like this.
Alright, thanks.